we have a bit of an update on the
layoffs that hit Microsoft yesterday and
following the wave of layoffs exhalo
infinite developers have criticized
incompetent leadership at Microsoft the
story from Eurogamer notes that stuff at
Bethesda game studios Gears of War
developer Coalition and Halo maker 343
Industries lost their jobs and as a
response Patrick Ryan who is a former
senior multiplayer designer on Halo
infinite and now working at respawn on
Jedi Survivor was one such former
employee who criticized the incompetent
leadership up top he said the layoffs at
343 shouldn't have happened that Halo
infinite should be in a better State the
reason for both of those things is
incompetent leadership up top during
Halo infinite development causing
massive stress on those working hard to
make Halo the best it can be the people
I worked every day with were passionate
about Halo and wanted to make something
great for the fans they helped push for
a better Halo and got laid off for it
devs still there are working hard on
that dream look at Forge be kind to them
during this time nice to get a little
bit of insight on what's gone wrong with
Halo because a lot of people have had a
lot of questions but do also love that
he shared the sentiment that a lot of
these devs are really really hard
working people and they've just been hit
with something very very difficult so
absolutely nothing but love to that team